hey everybody and welcome to a very
exciting wild ride with stevo i'll tell
you scott randolph couldn't even contain
his excitement as soon as we got done he
said man amanda cerny's a 14.
ivy dude she's an attractive lady no
doubt and this is a
terribly exciting episode but let me
tell you man you know how i was talking
about collecting pee i had this plan to
do the world record highest belly flop
ever into pure urine and we were all
saving pain into gallon jugs collected
over 190 gallons but the thing was that
those
gallons were so dark man i wasn't
drinking enough water man
turns out water's really good for you
and i've been going way out of my way to
drink a lot more of it and that's why
you always see me with these great
looking tall boys of water that look
like beers but really it's like the best
water out there it's called liquid death
and i'm telling you this company is the
best because they they use these cans
which are infinitely recyclable man
death to plastic that's the deal
so drink more water
don't mess with the plastic go with the
recyclable tall boys you got your
sparkling the mountain spring water and
if you go to
liquiddeth.com
stevo then you get a free set of koozies
with your first order of any case i'm
telling you man i drink it all the time
i feel better my pee looks better and
well my p doesn't look any better than
amanda cerny so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen amanda cerny yeah
i want you to meet my co-host scott
randolph chloe nice to meet you have you
guys met before never
okay but we're kindred spirits with the
ocd
yeah we we already bonded over our ocd
so that's great yeah
thank you so much for doing this um i
was so excited when um my manager told
me stevo was like hell yeah i haven't
seen or talked to you in like forever so
it's a great catch-up moment it really
isn't and uh you've been so kind to me
over the years you know like going back
to
i think the first time we met was right
before
i shattered my ankle
doing this thing that was 2016.
yeah with the the port-a-potty both
ankles oh yeah i broke both feet um but
i remember it at that time it i was
still pretty new
to to
kind of making the leap from like old
school entertainment into like digital
entertainment and i showed up at i don't
know if it was your place or someone
else's place but you guys
yeah you guys had this operation where
you were filming
these skits
with iphones and i was like man these
guys are like
like like
huge personalities and they're like
editing within an iphone it was so
counterintuitive to me
and well i i thought you were amazing
and super sweet because one you come
from such a strong entertainment
background and then here we are with our
iphones the shooting things and then
you're coming to collaborate with us and
i'm just like that is like the coolest
thing because especially at the time
when you did it a lot of people
didn't really understand it they didn't
really think it was a thing they didn't
understand the numbers behind it they
didn't understand like the potential of
it and then there you are right in the
beginning of it just diving full force
into it because you saw it so for me i
was just really impressed by that well
well thank you and and to be fair the
numbers were there at that time i mean
not the numbers that you've put together
since
but i think that collaborating with you
represented like the biggest bumps in my
like instagram following that i had
experienced so it was certainly a favor
that you did for me
and it's
so interesting to me too
the
like the the old versus the new
you know like i was always a huge howard
stern fan and he would be talking about
youtube like what is it i don't
understand views like what are we like
clicks like
how does that you know and then lo and
behold
you know all this meteoric success
and uh congratulations i mean wow you've
killed it
it's funny because a lot of
the people that started on vine and
youtube and like obviously had to like
carry it onto into instagram and other
platforms just because mine is no longer
around like thank god we did that but um
even at that time our goal
i i can't speak for everybody but my
goal was to get more into traditional
film and tv
but it it's
it's so interesting that we always
like we're having so much success on the
platforms that we're on in that moment
that we just
we want where the grass is greener on
the other side and then we're just like
oh no i need to do traditional film and
tv and then i'll like be successful so
it's it's funny to see that you were
coming from traditional into digital
work and it does give you a lot of
freedom because essentially you are your
own boss online and you can create your
own content you have that complete
freedom but there's something to say
about like going to a set and just being
able to play a character or just like
you know not have to think about every
single element of a production is kind
of nice as well so right it's an
interesting kind of um
you know experience both sides now and
seeing how like both are great in their
own way but so very different from each
other for sure
so you moved to florida
it's been a couple years already yeah
yeah i mean i'm from florida so my whole
family lives here my mom lives like
super close to me my sisters are like 30
minutes away
like miami's right there it's an easy
like travel hub and i'm always back and
forth between la still so cool yeah
we'll be out before soon i am yeah my my
family is still
in florida my sister is in boynton beach
oh shoot my sister's now moving
like uh to kind of the center of the
state in a random move but my dad's in
lake worth
oh cool yeah i mean i'm all
like southeast so
that's that's me as well i'm in um like
west palm beach area yeah stuart i mean
i'll never forget it was the stuart
playhouse i think
the 700 seat theater where the love
doctors there this these local radio djs
had a talent show and i called in i said
i'm stevo the alcoholic gymnast and i'm
going to pound a booze on stage until
i'm visibly drunk and then do acrobatics
and and that was in 1996 and the crowd
started chanting like steve oh they were
screaming steve oh and i remember
thinking dude they would never scream
steve
and that was like when i really
committed to being stevo was in stuart
florida at that time really 100 i
credited those
i credit the love doctors for me become
because i had been
kind of like thinking dude if i'm going
to have a real career and
try to be like a famous person do i want
to have this like corny goofy nickname
steve oh and i was conflicted about it
until i heard those people screaming in
stuart i'm so happy you came to stuart
because that was like
a great decision yeah i mean it's
too to think of stuart being the home of
amanda cerny
you know like it's
because once you get
north of like really west palm beach
then it becomes less glamorous kind of
florida
yeah
it's it's true but it's like
stuart's such a cute little like boating
town it's just really quiet i'm like
i don't i'm still understanding like
i i'm an introvert but i'm also like i
like to be out doing things and be
productive but i love being home like
i'm like a little hermit crab i just if
so for me it's like okay when i'm home
it's like my moment to just like reflect
and like set new goals and work on
different things and then i set myself
out into the world and i'm like okay and
now i'm like okay to do it because like
mentally i'm good so i remember
i remember the you know the few times
when when we worked together making
videos
thinking wow like you've got like sort
of different modes you know it's like
sure okay now you're on camera you're
you're being funny talented and then all
of a sudden like you switch into like
this needs to be there that means you
know like
like super producer and like you know
like it was really impressive
yeah i was i was super impressed by all
that and uh oh my god i remember it did
it like
it was uh the last time that we filmed a
video amanda and i i showed up with lux
right and uh lux and i were like pretty
new in our relationship
i'm gonna level with you this story i'm
about to share is totally embarrassing
for me and you know what else is really
embarrassing body odor man and with this
crazy summer heat we're all sweating
more than ever but we don't have to
stink more than ever if we choose the
right deodorant and i choose native why
because they don't test on animals super
important they don't have aluminum which
clogs your pores and does all kinds of
scary things to your health and they
only use ingredients that i've heard of
that i know what they are like coconut
oil shea butter i'm telling you this is
a great company with great values and an
even greater product which doesn't
compromise on performance keeps me
smelling good and feeling good all
summer with this crazy heat i'm telling
you i wish scott randolph would use it
because he might stink a lot but hey you
don't have to stink a lot and you can
get a killer deal on it right now by
going to
native
d-e-o
dot com slash stevo that's
dot n-a-t-i-v-e-d-e-o.com slash devo
that's gonna get you twenty percent off
your first order and you're gonna have a
great time ordering because they have
ten different awesome scents to choose
from my personal favorite is a coconut
and vanilla
i love it who knows what your favorite's
gonna be because all ten cents are
amazing now you go to one more time
native
d-e-o dot com slash devo or just use the
promo code stevo but get on over there
because that's 20 off your first order
and this company is going to leave you
smelling good and feeling good now let's
get into that embarrassing story
you know so she's just like checking
stuff out oh yeah i'm going to go over
and do this thing so i show up at amanda
cerny's place with lux and i've got the
bottle of the lotion dove dishwasher
which looks like semen
and like in my head and i'm like oh i've
got this great skit like i'm gonna like
you're gonna leave you did that with lux
there's my lugs was there and i'm like
squirting fake [ __ ] all over the place it
was like the most like wildly
uncomfortable
like i mean dude like for how funny i
thought it was i don't think that was
like i think most people were like um
okay
i mean
i
like i'm like all right everybody has
their own like
humor you know you're hilarious like for
you like you loved in that moment i'm
like i'm all in all right this is like
this is your video let's do it you do
you steve
you do you literally yeah
yeah you were a great sport
oh my god i think maybe maybe i'll dig
that one up and repost it to support my
supermarket
what was lux doing the whole like oh
yeah that was great babe
like that was the first date
like how is she doing by the way she's
fantastic she's working right now she
gives you her best she's working on an
uggs uh shoot
she does like um
like prep prop styling and and wardrobe
and stuff she's she's art department for
uh will this uh podcast air before the
dania beach dates because if so it'd be
a great oh yeah
a great chance to give it a little plug
right that's true we're coming into the
bucket list show in dania beach which is
what venue it's a new right now it's
brilliant
but i saw on your tour dates the dania
beach is and i've never heard of any of
these yeah it's the fort lauderdale area
and um the venue is it's an improv it's
it's a comedy club that's awesome i've
noticed a lot of different comedians are
going there and like for for their tours
and stuff lately and then i saw yours
and i saw dania beach and i looked up
where it was because i saw it on like
esther's do you know esther pavinski i
don't
know she's hilarious she's like um a
convenient a comedian then a good friend
of mine but she um has her show there
too and that made me look it up and then
i saw yours and yours is end of august
right yeah
and i'm
totally gonna go
oh well that would mean the world to me
and and when i see like you know my post
liked by amanda cerny i just i'd always
think man that's so cool you know like
it's it's so cool
how many instagram followers do you have
at this point yeah over 30 right
i have like
25 oh i thought it was i think you were
like 28 don't know do you look at people
with like 15 like ah dude
like one one day
yeah that's that's crazy um
so
the i i'll never forget to i think it
was right around the time that you left
l.a
maybe a little bit before
all of a sudden like the guests
like
i mean was that like huge to be like
yeah
it's guess jeans is it a jean company
but they're like they're like major high
fashion like yeah they're worlds
worldwide yeah to me the face of guests
was like yeah i was shocked i
was like really they want me to do that
but um yeah so i was the face of guests
for a year and then um just done
different campaigns with them but it was
insane like i've been
so cool to see your face on the side of
a skyscraper and be like and they even
put my name on all the advertisements
and everything too i'm like
freaking awesome like what brand does
that and for me i'm so used to
um just a lot of like no's in the
traditional space so
to get a yes from them and interest
coming from them to be the face of their
campaign i was shocked and it was
something like when i was younger i
always wanted to do and i would always
see the billboards but like when i was
little i got bit by a dog on the side of
my face and i had to get like 52
stitches when i was like 10. i was like
i am
never gonna be a
model ever in my life like that was like
my mindset and then
you know being the face of gas i'm like
wow i'm really proved myself wrong there
like
and i'm super interested that you said
uh
you know did houston knows instead does
that mean it was you and your team who
approached guess
no so it actually happened because i did
this music video and it was um with red
one french montana
um
who else was in it it was just like a
mix of all these different artists and
it was in morocco where we filmed it and
guests sponsored the video so it was
just all so like
random but awesome and put together and
um so that's how we got to know each
other was through that video and then
one of the girls abla that worked at
guess really advocated for me to become
the face of a campaign and then paul
marciano um followed me and saw all my
comedy sketches and he was like i really
like that you're a personality
and that you know you have a lot more to
you than
you know
some might say
pretty
thank you and then um so i went and i
went in the office i met everyone and
then from there it just i got the
confirmation that they were going to
move forward with the campaign so it was
pretty cool
super cool and that really represented
like a breakthrough moment for like
digital personality being like
mainstream like huge billboards like
yeah it was it was awesome
like i i just remember going underneath
the billboards and being like doing
those cheesy photos of just yourself
under a billboard
like oh
like i didn't post that but
yeah i remember being duct taped to a
billboard
you are so awesome i have so many
questions for you scott
and i i'm horrible with names usually i
have to say it like three times i got it
right it's chad that's absolutely scary
you could have done that to me i would
have felt so horrible and by all means
ask anything you want it's it we're easy
oh good well first off how did you two
oh boy she really couldn't have asked us
a much more sensitive question than that
and you know what we really couldn't
have given her a much more sensitive
answer
and speaking of sensitive can i tell you
that my nether regions are very delicate
that's why it is so important to me to
wear me undies underwear because the
fabric is breathable it could not be
more comfortable and it's very
sustainably made that's why i love this
company man me undies and their styles
are endless this underwear is just plain
cool man and i want you to try it
because you're gonna love it as much as
i do plus don't take my word for it me
andy's has a confidence level in their
product that's unmatched if for any
reason you don't like it you send it
back no problem
no questions just get your money back
but it's not going to happen because
you're going to love them here's the
deal meundies.com
stevo for 15 off your first order and
free shipping plus again if you don't
like it send it back got your money back
no questions asked
and if you join the membership even
better dude then you get discounted
pricing free shipping and early access
to all the new cool styles so hey man
head on over to meundies.com don't
forget the slash devo and just start
picking it out man this is gonna change
the game for you step up your underwear
game right now
now let's get into this vulnerable stuff
i i was approaching 40 years old
and thinking that that my lifestyle of
uh
of of being
basically
promiscuous wasn't the
the road to happiness and i i just felt
like it's becoming kind of a bad look
and it's i don't want to be that i feel
like if i want to be happy in life i
need to learn how to have a healthy
relationship and so i addressed those
issues
and i got very very serious about sexual
sobriety and at one point uh facing a
bunch of tour dates i just
i needed help
on the cock-blocking side so scott i
said scott
like you know i really want to be
serious about about uh you know a
healthy approach
to my life and and and not acting out
sexually can you come on tour with me
share a hotel room with me
and sell my merch so that you're right
there and actually be a formal
professional cockblocker
and that's amazing
um
yes i think i've got
to be the one i'll let him
so i i uh
i ran into steve
uh in the same
general area of that uh program we were
both double winners in uh 12-step
recovery meaning that we both had issues
with drugs and alcohol as well as
compulsive sexual acting out and so i
knew that scott was uh what you know
dealing with the same issues and and
kind of on the same page
so as a function of fellowship
and and working towards becoming the man
that the love of my life deserves you
know i had a lot of work to do to get
ready to meet lux you know
and yeah and so that was what brought
scott and i together was uh it was doing
that work
and um scott scott would take a bullet
for this dick
yeah i mean
yeah like we
we were successful in that and um and
then i started so then the first oh yeah
the first show scott shows up he's like
all you sell is t-shirts and books you
don't even have a credit card swiper and
he put together this merchandising
empire and now all these years later
scott's my tour manager my business
partner my co-producer like my co-host
you know like we've really really built
a lot and and by
by eliminating the distractions and the
stress of all the you know like
acting out it's it's really allowed me
to to narrow my focus and be super
deliberate and not waste my time and and
as a result we've been able to
to achieve some pretty some pretty big
things
yeah you got a good circle around you i
feel like that's one of the
the most important things towards
success is just having people around you
that are like going to motivate you in
the right direction and are like-minded
so you guys were like-minded in the
cock-blocking strategy and then
all the success so far also also you got
to put people around you who fill in
your holes you know like where like you
know scott and i are very much a yang
yin and yang
because like
he's he's a morning person like i'm not
you know like i'm like super creative
he's super administrative you know like
we really complement each other a lot
but i wanted to ask you you've been i i
knew you for years and uh had no idea
what uh what your situation was but
you've been in a relationship that whole
the whole time
yeah
um i'm trying to think in 2015
um
yeah so i i think i was in another
relationship when i first met you and
then that relationship ended and then i
started in a different relationship with
johannes who i've been with for
i don't even know
how long it's been like i'm so horrible
with time but we started and it's
confusing because we started off as like
close friends at first especially when i
was like in my long-distance
relationship we were just like close
friends and that ended like johannes
swooped right on in and then um so then
we were like kind of hooking up and you
know still friends but not exclusively
dating because i just got out of a
relationship and then we were finally
like okay like we're together all the
time and we like being around each other
and then we ended up just
dating and then it just happened so
organically because we lived in the same
building too that building that you went
to the 16th century 500 vine and it's
still going fine i wonder i i mean it's
almost like visiting your old um middle
school or high school
if you go
it's a little bit more like a college
dorm oh there you go yeah
i probably said middle school because
like there were also influencers living
in there that were like
15. really
yeah from like middle of america like
just moved out just to work on their
career in social media by themselves and
lived in the building at 15
yeah i don't doubt it i i don't doubt it
at all um and now like it started out
like sort of vine centric like uh now
like tick tock is i i've
i've got a buddy living there
i've got this buddy spencer x and he's
on like the penthouse floor like
you know he's uh wow he's like the king
batch of vine so it's like the higher
the floor the more like influential you
are i guess so
he told me he's just moving out of there
now but are you active on tick tock as
well i mean you got to be right yeah i
do check talk i mostly do instagram i
have the most fun on there i just like
how organic it is with stories and like
actually i still
do sketches here and there vlogs like
lifestyle stuff you did
you did make the leap to youtube
um
kind of like i've always had youtube but
i kind of do my vlogs on igtv i think
they call it like i don't even know if
they call it igtv still it's just like
long form and right right
you know i was doing the igtv thing and
then i saw the retention rate because
like it plays for 15 seconds and then
you have to actually click keep watching
and like
way few people click keep watching and
that hurts my feelings yes
just give them an incentive around 14
seconds you know i try
like i'll subtitle the first 15 seconds
i'll get a cold open
oh i mean i don't know if you had like a
a teaser of what was about to happen oh
my god i was on your instagram and i saw
the the poop in the eardrum oh yeah
yeah how was your ear by the way dude i
i i went to the to the doctor for my
two-week follow-up and he said that the
hole in my eardrum closed
on its own
i'm almost completely magnified
like there's yeah i don't think there's
poop inside now
okay that's good
they cleaned it out well yeah well that
was the thing i don't think i don't
think the poop actually
broke my eardrum i think that it was
when i went in to get it flushed out the
the flushing of the water didn't
puncture your eardrum it was probably
the 1800 psi
air gun to your side of your face that
broke
out maybe i'm going to go with scott
yeah
so you said you'd come back to l.a all
the time and uh and and
like like what generally it's for work i
i presume yeah why not productive in l.a
right
but like this this is where we do so
much on on the podcast we we speak with
wildly successful people and we try to
kind of glean from them their playbook
on how like they become so successful
which makes me dying to ask you like
what types of different business
initiatives bring you to la like what
what are you most active doing these
days
well i'm always active creating um it's
honestly where i feel
like the most excited whenever i'm just
like you know working on different
projects or even just producing
different projects so like right now i i
really want to produce a rom-com so i
just started working on that and then
you know that's the whole process in
itself and then being out in la and
meeting with like different writers and
all that is kind of a fun process but
i'm always creating stuff for instagram
for social media so you know in la like
a bunch of influencers live out there
and like collaborating has been like my
whole life through like vine
youtube everything and it's just it
makes it more fun because you get to see
your friends and be productive with your
friends so i think that's great
um and then also like i've gotten
involved in the crypto space
yeah me too can you talk about uh which
coin you're investing in
at the moment um i am happy well i have
a lot of holds right now because like
you're a hodler
i'm a hobbler
and
i'm like all right hold on but um so
i'm a strong believer in bnb
so that's a it's the binance coin
so that's one of like the biggest
exchanges and then um
i also am a fan of the doge i know it's
a meme coin but i believe in the people
that are behind it like elon musk i
think you know he has to have a strategy
for what he's doing so i bet on that um
so that's definitely a bet because the
coin has no utility really it's just
kind of
kind of there and you got to believe in
the people behind it and hope uh it goes
to
the moon but
so that's kind of like a way riskier one
but then again i don't really think so
because i have a lot of doge i have like
over seven million coins and doge so wow
good for you yeah that's that that
that's got to be a juicy piece of
information yeah that that stock's going
to push a little bit
well and of course ethereum and bitcoin
you know what about cardano
i i like cardano i don't have it but i
like it so i i see a lot of people
posting it's like it's so much to watch
it's not all that i do but you know and
i'm in all these like
uh chats and you know little groups
about crypto with people who like do it
full time and that is their livelihood
they manage funds for other people so
for me i get juicy bits of information
from there as well but i have to be
realistic with myself and i can't spend
myself especially if i'm managing my own
portfolio which i really love to do
whether it's in crypto or if it's in the
stock market i just like like knowing
where my money is and what it's doing
and i've always been like that um is
that ocd that's an ocd thing right cause
i'm the same way i love to manage my own
portfolios
yeah but it makes it makes you wonder if
it's oh but before i go into that like i
want to know what coins you're in before
you leave crypto
uh ethereum doge and cardano oh cool
yeah yeah we're we're together we're on
this devo are you in crypto the only
crypto i have is from the underwhelming
nft sale that i did which was uh in
ethereum
i think uh okay i'm trying to remember
what it was
i started the auction at like one eath
which at the time i believe was about
three thousand dollars and like by the
time the the auction was over or
whatever the the sale was made it was
like
1.00 like or i forget what one point
what it was but i bought money's money
money's money but yeah i only say
underwhelming because the numbers that
we were hearing like like logan paul
like like with five million bucks in 24
hours like you know never compare stevo
yeah that's the way to success
well i mean i i understand don't compare
but i set the bar really high at the
scene at the same time you know like i
remember when i first signed with the
full screen which got me motivated to do
like
disciplined regular youtube posting
i was i walked in there and i said i'm
looking at like the paul brothers i'm
looking at all these people like and i'm
trying to figure out like what am i not
doing like i'm not lazy like i'm ready
to work like let me figure it out and i
think by comparing i got motivated to
just
figure it out and and work harder and
and uh work smarter so i like true i
like i like like a little bit of healthy
jealousy
yeah yeah that's good as long as you're
not uh
putting down your accomplishments oh
yeah no i'm not i'm not at all but yeah
i haven't been too concerned with with
with crypto
yeah
how much of your uh business is is in
branded like integrated posting
um
well
i don't really have it divided with i
would say you know i have a good
chunk of long-term partnerships
so for me like i just uh
launched um
a long long collaboration we've been
working on this product for a while
which is our bald move shave kit so i
started that with um truly beauty so i
just launched that i started um 626 wine
that's a company that i own with my best
friend king batch so
we drink wine all the time we're like
why not start why not why not
and then
and then um yeah so it's just like
working on things that you know i have
equity in that i also have real interest
in and then yeah you do the things that
are here and there that like you know
you you learn about and you like the
product and you try it out and it's good
and it all makes sense coming together
and then you can do campaigns like that
but
i i i like to think of longevity as well
with it because if i
sell out on every single like post and
every single thing it's like you know
people are smart they're going to see
and they're just going to be like okay
like why are we here so for me it's like
i like to do things that i'm heavily
involved in and heavily like on the back
end of it but i like that
i like that a lot and here i'm thinking
that the only reason i don't do more
brand integration is because i can't get
more brand integration
like people are like oh we don't really
need the [ __ ] in the ear guys
they're asking you to be on billboard
steve's putting himself on billboards
that's great i'm going to talk tech
buying him myself
he's like you don't want to put me on
the billboard he's going to buy the
billboard and then tape himself to it
would you say that brands are more
open-minded today
than they used to be or they're more
conservative or about the same super
open-minded i mean it just depends on
what it is there's certain brands are
just never gonna [ __ ] with me and that's
fine and it's it's better i mean it's
better because like my social media feed
really isn't a bunch of uh you know
branded stuff i'm always trying to sell
my own merch but i like to keep the the
promos for my merch like at the end of a
video where i've already delivered like
some quality entertainment you know
nobody knows yeah like i'm always gonna
tuck it in at the end and like really
make it my priority to to give people
something that they're glad that they
saw
that's great it's all about balance and
giving value whether it's like
extra incentive or hookups for your
audience or just like that awesome
content that you always produce so
nobody produces content like you like
i can never do what you do and likewise
i think that you making a rom-com is an
absolute slam dunk
i mean
really [ __ ] yeah i mean your your your
content's hilarious
you know your audience is massive like
like your your mainstream you're
established i think that that that that
should be the first conversations with
who's uh
ryan gosling no no no the um
the guy did a
train wreck with uh
train wreck that they did train wreck
with amy schumer that director oh uh
yeah dude the guy he also did funny
people he did uh
the guy that everybody knows but doesn't
know that he's pulling this up is it me
or no he's uh
yeah
you know what the
the best rom-com probably of the last 40
years was that uh
movie long shot with charlize theron and
seth rogen have you ever seen that i've
never seen it it's the funniest movie
i've probably ever seen in the last 20
years
we have different tastes in music it was
pretty good but i don't know
amanda can do way better
what was the one i love the classic
rom-coms when harry met sally
yeah i mean it's great but what was the
one with uh david spade and um
yeah yeah yeah yeah um
the wrong girl the other girl something
like that
we suck we're never gonna get into korea
no we just they're wrong
yeah they're wrong
yeah yeah yeah we enjoyed that so funny
i mean it's not your typical rom-com but
it was hilarious like she did amazing in
that yeah she was very talented
i'm happy you think that's good for me
because i feel like that's good for me
too so i think i think it's a no-brainer
and when you said that i'm like dude i
can't believe you didn't already do it i
know well that's how i feel is there
hence your bucket list i mean
like for me that's something that i've
always wanted to do and i still haven't
done it so it's like all right well you
know why i haven't done it because i
didn't have a scott telling me eye on
the prize
so i need a [ __ ]
blocker to fill in my hole
amanda's bucket amanda's bucket list is
like i want to film a rom-com steve's
like i want to blow a load while jumping
out of an airplane
who's to say what's wrong and right
right but
i i want to hear um
is there something off your bucket list
that you haven't been able to do that i
haven't been able to get cauliflower
here some people just can't get
cauliflower here and no matter how much
it's like you should have it already i
know
i think it's just you it's like what
steve will do instead there's no such
thing as losing in vegas it's just
quitting
yeah
right i mean get to a point where like
you know and lux doesn't want me to have
cauliflower here anyway so maybe that's
just as well what about a boob
yeah
i'm sorry lux
yeah don't do it though if it's not
meant to be it's not yeah
there's a couple of things that we
haven't done yet like i i just recently
purchased a smart car
just so that i can
crash it into a brick wall to make sure
that the airbags work
oh my god the little one yeah yeah and
i'll be all dressed up like a crash test
dummy it'll be cute
yeah yeah but
we're just getting ready to do that yeah
that's funny when we were buying the
smart car they're trying to like upstail
us on like the warranty and the
insurance like
and that like finally we're like look
we're just gonna crash this in the next
seven minutes so
you don't need to upsell us on anything
yeah but how how did this list
okay so you have ideas and then
who do you do you
even bother pitching it or is it just
like no no no no no no
wait it's it started out because i got
into stand-up you know i started touring
as a stand-up like 10 years ago and and
i did like my first comedy special which
was pretty traditional in the way i
performed it
and then as i put together my second
comedy special
i started editing in
the footage of the stories that i was
telling in my act so it was this
multimedia affair and that went so
spectacularly well for me i really
stumbled on this multimedia stand-up
comedy that when i started putting
together my third show
now i wanted to go out and film
exclusive like just over the top crazy
stuff to make an act out of and then
after each bit i screen the exclusive
footage
and in doing that i was like okay well
i've kind of done it all except i know
that i've got like a bunch of ideas that
were just way too out there to ever like
really be serious about doing and now
i'm gonna be serious about doing them so
i call it my bucket list and
you know i had the vasectomy olympics
like which is super gnarly like the like
blowing a load simultaneously while i
fall out of an airplane
like uh
anesthesia general anesthesia coming
through an iv like while i'm hauling ass
on a bicycle
like like pretty high level stuff and uh
and so i did it all like like never mind
how illegal it is how x-rated it is like
because i had nothing stops me from
bringing it on tour and so that's what
i'll be doing in dania beach
yeah so it's already you've done it all
already for the most part yeah
for the most part and i've incorporated
like the the the actual comedy show is a
journey through
this absurd bucket list
and and uh it's as much a story about my
relationship with lux because to do all
that stuff it inherently has
implications on my relationship
and then like
so it's just
all this crazy stuff and it's it's this
you know pretty polished act and after
each bit like there's a screening of uh
of the results
that's
amazing that you put that together and
then also just amazing that you still
think of even crazier things than you've
already have done like
for me do you ever have um
any just like writer's block or like
did you already have this list ready of
things that you wanted to do or was it
like coming up with them most of it most
of it was uh i was sitting on for a long
long time and just like there were crazy
ideas just to say
you know some of it just came up
naturally
i already know what the next tour is
gonna be what my fourth show will be and
that's gonna be like it's called gone
too far
where i actually go in for like uh
you know surgical breast augmentation
and i get like a flower ear yeah
and uh i've been doing the the gone too
far is is one [ __ ] and i gotta make
the phone calls to make it happen
yeah that's going to suck but how much
fun did like we had amanda's turning on
and and uh she
had legit questions
so i got to talk about me
he's like do you want to come on next
week too
i'm not i'm not interested in me i'm
like i'm bored with talking i don't like
talking about myself so i much rather
talk about
you and all the things that you're
working on so i catch a lot of [ __ ] from
uh in the comments like shut up let her
talk
no oh my god oh i hope the comments are
nice but then again whatever it's
internet you're gonna get both sides
right but
and is that something that ever like
actually is too cliche of a question
never mind i retract it all right it's
fine
what um
like you strike me as uh like a socially
conscious like good person
and i wonder what like
causes are important to you like for me
like animals is is my thing and and i
love that about you and i love that sea
world uh
yeah
but and you know like i'm a dog lover
myself i have my pups and i'm obsessed
with them and i totally like
don't know how people can be cruel to
animals and that's the first thing that
makes me cry in a movie and in real life
and seeing all the clips online like i
love that you do that and to me that's
so amazing um for me it's the same like
i've been vegan for over
i don't even know i'm horrible with time
but over 10 years wow and then
um and for me it's like
like i wouldn't even think of it started
for health reasons i was like okay it's
healthier lifestyle because i'll be more
conscious about what i'm eating and then
you slowly learn more and more and more
about the things as you go down the
rabbit hole of something and then you're
like whoa
like this is so important so
for me that's huge
environment that's also huge i mean we
all utilize it we need it this is like
our everyday so it's like showing some
things back into the world and i'm a
heavy believer in
karma and i'm a heavy believer in you
know
just
you have to do things that you're
passionate about and you can't spread
yourself too thin and especially when
you're working towards different causes
like it's great to do things here and
there and promote awareness here and
there but sticking to specific causes
really makes
an impact on those causes and that's
what i've learned because i used to try
to do just like everything i was like
how can i help
use me whatever like whatever platform
you need where can i show up and help
out like even for my guest campaign i
was like can we do a charitable
component to all the sales in this and
just like pick um a town and turkey to
help out with because we know
places we launched it was like help the
children at the orphanage and then um so
it's just like
i i was spreading myself really thin
with that and now it's just like i focus
a lot with the united nations i work
with them on just like promoting
awareness about the environment and the
different impacts and also just like
raising funds for different causes just
to promote educational content as well
just because i feel like
one of the best things we can provide to
people is education and awareness to you
know make it so they actually care
enough to make the changes in their own
lives that will create the most impact
so that's kind of like what i've learned
over the years i guess that's epic well
i have a question for both of you guys
and i think i already know the answer
but i just i want to ask it anyways if
you guys both had 100 million dollars to
start your own cause what would the
cause be
i would buy it
well talking about environment but i
would buy a plantation probably and just
like
load it up with dogs i think and just
like start starting
those rescued dogs from
yeah
like i feel like that's so selfish of me
though because that's what all dog
people say because they love dogs so
much yeah i love them so much so like
maybe i should you know create document
more documentaries maybe i should like
go to areas and provide resources for
education it's a that's a
nobody has offered me that yet so i
didn't i like to do my back-end research
and uh i'll work on that
yeah you would do dogs obviously i mean
animals
like we want to open up an animal
sanctuary and and uh i think that
there's a lot to be said for
having an experience
with an animal like i think if more
people like hung out with with cows if
they had the opportunity to to like pet
a cow look into its eyes and see like
wait a second
like
you know
so i don't know
i like the idea of
creating a a place for people to have
that experience to really give uh
you know some weight to animals
where does that
love
for animals come from with you like in
your childhood
did you have pets did you or was it i
had pets um
it started out like when i was a circus
clown like i thought like uh
you know the the animals in the circus i
was just like wait a second this sucks
for them you know like you but you're
like um
you love your dog so much that like we
would fly home
we would be working all night and then
he would want to fly home at like 6 a.m
just to be with his dogs when we first
started working you know and but were
you like that with your dogs when you're
growing up
yeah are you you always were
pretty much except when i was growing up
i was even worse and like smothering
them really you know like i'm like with
with my dogs i'm like the grandma that's
like pinching your cheeks and it's like
okay you know and like she doesn't she
loves you but it's like okay good enough
you know like that's how i am with my
dog they're like they're like okay with
the [ __ ] all right i didn't know that
about you i didn't know you're always
like that with all your with your dogs
pretty much yeah
can i ask what you because i have like
basically two puppies i have one that's
a year old one that's like nine weeks
old and i'm obsessed like
i'm a crazy dog lady and that's
completely what i want to be in my life
and that's perfect um
but then i'm like oh [ __ ] i have to
travel still
and i need to get a nanny i think yeah
so
we we have at our house
a little barn in the back with
three goats running around the backyard
we put them up at night we let them out
in the morning we got four dogs in the
house two cats and absolutely if we're
not gonna be home like it is not okay to
just leave the the house so yeah we have
uh we have people
the pet sitters that we we let them know
like hey we're gonna be out of town like
can you stay
live at our house
and take care of our babies yeah because
i'm going to have like a whole list of
you gotta cuddle at least four hours a
day 100 lux is the requirements yeah
because they need the cuddles yeah like
i was talking to one of my friends and
then she was like um talking about dogs
sleeping outside and i was like
how
like without with just by itself
and then she was just explaining to me
how that's like normal for some people
and i'm just like i couldn't i couldn't
like in my dogs if i did that i think
they would just like die
like i think they'd be so sad right um
not only are dogs inside but like we
like
like i i
lure them on to the bed with treats
you know like because we we want
like we we
really want all four dogs on the bed
with us like all the time and then like
with like the what what happens we can i
call it the dine and dash i lure them
onto the bed with treats they eat them
and then they're like okay cool we're
out
mine let me pick him up and put him in a
like a baby position and then i'll lay
him right next to me and lay his head
like right on my chest and he'll stay
there for like a good 20 minutes and
then he'll slowly start to creep away
and then when i realize when i go to
grab him he just darts out of the room
and like your heart drops a little in
that moment you're just like uh we have
that completely in common a hundred
percent that's great
but the thing is with me and this is
like something you know i always like
kick myself over it's like i do have two
dalmatians
i didn't get them from a shelter
like i am like not as
apparently i'm not as good as a human as
you are but um
i got back on fish
so sad so i'm over here eating fish like
okay see it's and that's one thing to do
like and the reason why i have
dalmatians i'm like i feel like i have
to justify my dalmatians but like i
when i was little i had one when i was
like five years old and
again i don't i'm not good with time and
then um
my parents gave it away
and back to
where they got it from and then i
just remember crying every night being
like i'm gonna own
or like i'm gonna mother so many
different dalmatians and i would dress
up as a dalmatian like i have childhood
pictures of me like full on dalmatian
with a nose and ears going to school
dressed like that and then i'm like okay
like i don't think you have to justify
anything and i think that i think that
the biggest problem with animal advocacy
is infighting between like people who
are advocates for animals but feel that
other advocates for animals aren't
advocating enough like you're not vegan
enough and it's like wait wait a second
guys we're all on the same team you know
we're all working towards
let's recognize progress let's let's
encourage what people do
exactly like and that's
nobody's perfect and you can't be
perfect like
no matter how hard you try like you
cannot be perfect and that's something
that you know i've realized too it's
like all right you know
i'm doing a lot i can always do more and
i can always grow and be better but at
the same time it's like i feel good
about what i do thus far and i feel like
i'm doing pretty good
like
and and same thing like and i see that a
lot online too and that's why like i
even sometimes like refrain from calling
myself vegan because i'm afraid of
like people attacking me for
having honey sometimes and i'm like
right
i couldn't agree more i couldn't agree
more like and and what upsets me more
than anything
is uh
the
the way that the the vegan community
will
will really be deceptive like to you
know some of these documentaries like
when they're saying
you've got documentaries saying sugar
doesn't cause diabetes it's animal
products like it's like okay you know
like how
if you google like the title of certain
vegan documentaries
like debunking them it's like you know
this it's just pages and pages of i'm a
doctor and that's [ __ ] i'm a vegan
and that's [ __ ] and i'm like it's it
represents a step backwards people don't
like being lied to once you tell them
something that's not true then they're
never going to take you seriously ever
again and now you've just hurt the cause
by like you know misleading people and
i'm particularly pissed about it because
i'm in the [ __ ] documentary you know
they put me in it and they put me in the
[ __ ] documentary and then i'm like oh
i see it what is this it's called what
the health
oh
yes everybody was talking i need to
watch it now everybody
get ready to see a bunch of factually
wrong
[ __ ] you know what i'm just really
excited for them
like i'm excited to do the back end
research and be like oh [ __ ]
yeah i mean like and and whatever but
but i just think that we should be
promoting progress we should be
promoting compassion and we should be
doing so with honesty and integrity
yeah and not um
you know just being listening and then
also just like not drilling people like
i see some like some of these um
platforms that are like vegan platforms
or environmentalists and like people
that i follow that follow me back and i
see like some of them
posting the most
stuff and then just like saying calling
people names and like that's how they
interact about like getting people to
understand what they're saying is
important and i'm like
i like who's gonna listen to that i
would never listen to somebody who's
yelling at me right ever like i'm not i
would never learn that way i would be
scared and i'd be like yes
and then like go away right but
i would only really listen if somebody
was like hey like this is the facts
behind this like you know and just said
it in a
in a different way but you know then
again that's the internet but it's also
you see companies doing that and you're
like
for sure
so is there a is there anything that for
the people who we've retained that we
can direct them to
we lost them at dogs
like talking about how we cuddle our
dogs
no i think that was fun
i think that was fine but but yeah is
there is there anything and any calls to
action that we can share for um yeah
check out 6261.com
yeah
check out my social media i'm always
posting on instagram amanda cerny i'm on
tick tock i'm everywhere um
and
yeah what's that what's fine
is 626 the area code
it's my birthday and also my best
friend's birthday oh wow how about that
i'm 6 13. i was born in the 626 area
code that's what i was going to say is
pasadena
i see now you just have to have it to
represent i know so the um
the shape kit where do we get that
um that's truly beauty.com and is that
for dudes as well as chicks or just
chicks i mean the scents are a little
bit feminine but uh if you like fruity
like
pretty sense
are you in the cosmetics game just like
everybody else
i i would say i'm into like health and
wellness and for me like i i like oils i
like um skincare so yeah all right
i'm i'm a variety show myself okay so
truly beauty
six juice it's truly beauty.com
626wine.com
six26
we we went fancy
six
two six
wow
it's like six nine
that's what we were going for
for sure i love it okay and it's at
amanda cerny across the the boards
across all platforms oh it's early yep
and uh and and be compassionate and kind
to animals
and don't yell love each other
one love don't yell at people comments
or not
yeah adopt a dalmatian
technically
yeah i'm just going to be ready though
you're going to have me start talking
about dalmatians now oh yeah i'm not i'm
not uh i don't think i'm gonna have to
justify anything and i'm so i'm so
grateful i'm so honored that we got to
do this i uh yes i really really do
appreciate you
and uh again congrats on all of your
success it's really incredible
you know just to see this meteoric
explosion of your uh mainstream
popularity has been a real treat thank
you and thank you guys so much for
having me on your podcast like wild ride
yeah all right
see you in dania beach i love that so
much thank you i'm excited yeah dude
that that was an exciting wild ride
and i know some people are gonna be like
ah dude stevo [ __ ]
talked about himself but dude she was
asking me questions about myself so and
my answers were entertaining i think i
think that was a
badass episode and as always the people
who stick around to the very end you're
the ones who matter most to me so thank
you very very much yeah dude it's an
exciting time and it's a wild ride whoa